thank you very much it's a pleasure to
address a group dedicated to the
principle of full financial disclosure
I'm pleased not only to be here but to
be here with with so many members of the
Securities and Exchange Commission
accounting staff in attendance those of
you who are out there should know that
that at the Chairman's office at least
we consider your efforts to be extremely
important to the Commission and in our
current hiring at the division of
corporation finance level we are
emphasizing the hiring of accountants as
as extremely important to our to our
efforts I was struck by the introduction
I couldn't quite tell whether our
Chairman was saying that the former
chairman was in the Netherlands and the
current chairman is in never-never land
but I I have found that since I have
become chairman that that matters have
become even more exciting than I
expected and I have tried in the course
of several speeches to emphasize matters
of importance to the audience that I am
addressing and it's a pleasure to deal
this morning with the Commission's full
disclosure program in the accounting
profession current issues and ongoing
improvements the importance of financial
disclosure was recognized at the time of
the 1933 Act the Securities Act of 1933
and its significance continues today
under our integrated the disclosure
system my remarks today will focus on
the accountants role in disclosure on
current proposals for enhancement of
that role and on current challenges for
the financial disclosure system
particularly in the international area
the disclosure system administered by
the SEC is essential to a healthy and
strong capital market in particularly in
particular accurate and complete
financial information enables investors
to evaluate past performance and to form
reasonable judgments about future
performance as you know full financial
disclosure includes not only the
contents of financial statements but
other components as well for example the
narrative information contained in
management's discussion and analysis is
important for evaluating and comparing
company performance concern with
financial disclosures and evitable leads
to focus on the accuracy completeness
and presentation of the information
disclosed here the accountant occupies
center stage within the company the
accountant supervises the recording of
financial data and the initial
preparation of financial statements and
both inside accountants and external
auditors bear responsibility for
accuracy and presentation of financial
information finally the certification
process tells the public at large that a
responsible independent third-party has
reviewed the data presented and tested
its accuracy as the agency charged with
the responsibility to oversee the
accuracy and completeness of financial
disclosures the Commission has also
accepted responsibility for oversight of
the accounting profession happily over
the years the Commission has been able
to do so by recognizing the guiding
principle of private sector
standard-setting it is the private
accounting profession acting with
commissioned guidance that assures the
integrity and credibility of the
disclosure system now integrity and
credibility arise first from the quality
of the accounting standards used to
develop financial information the
Commission applauds development of
quality accounting standards by the
Financial Accounting Standards Board and
we will continue our partnership with a
private sector in setting these
accounting standards although the
Commission has its own accounting rules
contained in regulation xsx the primary
function of these rules is to supplement
fasb standards and perhaps sometimes to
serve as interim guidance a second
important
e to the integrity and credibility of
financial prepara financial reporting is
auditor examination of financial
information under auditing standards set
by the American Institute of Certified
Public Accountants known to all of us as
the aicpa an objective standing of
compliance with accounting and
disclosure standards is essential if
disclosure if disclosures are to be
reliable and perceived as reliable the
quality and honesty of the honest of the
auditors themselves is of course
extremely essential the accounting
profession must maintain the highest
ethical standards expect expected by
those who rely on the accountants work
this expectation was forcefully
articulated by the Supreme Court in 1984
in Arthur Young versus the United States
in which the court stated the
independent auditor assumes a public
responsibility transcending any
employment relationship with the client
this public watch dog function which you
play demands that you maintain total
independence from your clients at all
times and requires complete fidelity to
the public trust the key to the
Commission's confidence in the
accounting profession as I've said lies
in cooperation with the FAS FAS be and
the AICPA these two private sector
organizations play crucial roles and
meeting financial disclosure obligations
each in turn reflects the feasibility of
private sector standard setting a good
example of our relationship with the FAS
FAS B is that organizations current
efforts to develop better accounting
standards for new financial instruments
and related transactions it is
increasingly common today to read about
exotic new types of securities in the
financial press the financial markets
are trading repurchase and reverse
repurchase agreements collateral
collateralized mortgage obligations and
other asset backed securities financial
guarantees interest rate swaps
common stocks with put features and loan
strips and many other novel instruments
the emergent emergence of many
significant questions about appropriate
accounting treatment of financial
instruments ultimately led the
Commission in june of 1985 to direct its
chief accountant to it to ask the fasb
to consider disclosure policies
regarding financial instruments and
related transactions the fasb responded
by establishing a project on accounting
for financial instruments and just a
month ago issued an exposure draft that
draft calls for increased disclosures
about all financial instruments whether
they are recognised in an entity's
financial statements or carried off book
the proposals would require information
about future cash flows interest rates
market values and risk exposures these
proposals represent an initial step in a
major fasb project that could have broad
implications across industry lines for
the measurement and recognition of
complicated transactions and instruments
they also represent the close
cooperation between the fasb and the SEC
in developing accounting standard the
Commission's relationship with the AICPA
includes its oversight of an auditing
standard setting by the AI CPAs auditing
standards board over the years the
Commission staff has encouraged and
monitored the board's efforts to provide
additional guidance to auditors and to
improve communications among auditors
registrant's and the auditors true
client the public this year a group of
new standards part of the ASB so-called
expectation gap project are expected to
be finalized the project is designed to
explain more clearly to the investing
public the auditors area of
responsibility and to expand upon those
areas in response to public comment
examples from proposals from the
expectation gap project include among
other things a proposal to make the
standard auditor's report more explicit
and to remove overly technical language
a proposal to clarify the auditors
responsibility to detect and report
financial fraud and the proposal to
require auditors to consider in each
audit the question whether the entity
will continue to exist standards alone
however will not meet the public's
expectation rather it is the performance
of individual auditors and accounting
firms in adhering to professional
standards by insisting that clients
prepare accurate financial statements
that will ultimately shape the public's
perception of whether accountants are
adequately performing their public watch
dog functions now when I say private
sector standard setting I mean to say
just that but I mean also to say that
the Securities and Exchange Commission
has great interest in its oversight
function regarding the private sector
functioning the role of the accountant
in enhancing the full disclosure system
is currently subject to both commission
and private sector initiatives the
Commission is correct currently
considering three rulemaking proposals
that if adopted would directly affect
the accounting profession these
proposals concern mandatory peer review
opinion shopping and the Commission's
ruled t2e in addition the report of the
National Commission on fraudulent
financial reporting the treadway
Commission contains many thoughtful
recommendations concerning the
profession I would like to discuss
briefly those three Commission proposals
and the treadway Commission report the
Commission's mandatory peer review
proposal if adopted would require an
independent assessment of auditing
quality control systems including a
judgment regarding the systems
protection against inferior audits the
Commission staff is currently preparing
a recommendation regarding peer review
which the Commission expects to consider
this early this year peer review is an
extremely important concept and although
I believe that the present program
conducted by the aai CPAs SEC practice
section has helped to improve the
quality controls of its member firms
much much
remains to be accomplished in the peer
review area and I will take a great
interest in seeing that the Commission's
proposals are moved forward promptly a
second proposed Commission rule if
adopted would increase disclosures
concerning changes in accountants and
possible opinion shopping situations the
term opinion shopping is not defined in
the accounting literature or the
auditing literature nevertheless it is
generally understood to involve the
search for an auditor willing to support
a proposed accounting treatment designed
to help a company achieved its reporting
objectives even though that treatment
might frustrate accurate reporting if
the perception exists that the auditors
opinion can be influenced by a
competitive business getting pressure
great dot will be cast over these
opinions regardless of the individual
circumstances surrounding them and the
profession should I believe have
interest in wiping out opinion shopping
occurring the Commission's form 8-k
requires disclosure of the resignation
or dismissal of an independent
accountant and information regarding the
existence and nature of any
disagreements are required in annual
reports and other filings even under
current rules the Commission staff
carefully reveals all disclosures
concerning changes in accountants
focusing particularly on the nature of
reported disagreements and of course
when opinion shopping results in false
or misleading statements the Commission
will pursue appropriate enforcement
action because of our concern about
opinion shopping we have welcomed the
AICPA auditing standards board statement
auditing standards number 50 has
guidance for accounting policy
considerations and we believe that its
guidelines have been helpful however the
Commission believes that enhanced
disclosures may be necessary and
therefore has has issued its current
rule proposal the proposed rule would
require new disclosures in form 8-k when
a registrant changes its outside auditor
it
also would identify more clearly
circumstances that would constitute a
reportable disagreement between the
registrant and the Auditor under the
proposal the term disagreement would be
interpreted broadly to include any
difference of opinion which if not
resolved to the auditors satisfaction
would have been referred to in the
auditor's report the proposed rule also
provides that if an auditor is not
re-engaged the register it must disclose
whether the registrant or the auditor
made the decision not to re-engage and
whether the decision was discussed with
a registrants audit committee or board
of directors this proposal came to us
from the AICPA and we have encoded in
our rule proposal if there were any
disagreements the registration
registrant must describe them state
whether the former auditor has discussed
them with the audit committee or board
and whether the former auditor was
authorized to discuss the matter
candidly with the new auditor I I will
not speculate on the outcome of the
Commission's deliberations other than to
say that the issues will be examined
very carefully as you know I it is not
customary to discuss in detail rule
proposals which are before the
Commission nevertheless I seem to be
doing some of that here a third
rulemaking initiative concerns the
clause in rule to e7 of the Commission's
rules of practice that certain rule to
eat proceedings be private rather than
public through rule 2e the Commission
protects the integrity of its processes
by disciplining professionals including
accountants who practice before it
actions may be brought based upon among
other things violations of the
securities laws or improper professional
conduct for accountants improper
professional conduct may involve
participation in an audit that is not
conducted in conformance with with
generally accepted accounting standards
or generally accepted accounting
principles although controversial rule 2
e has consistently been upheld by the
courts original to we proceedings that
is proceedings not derived from
court-ordered injunctions or findings of
violations generally are can
in private unless the Commission on its
own motion or at the request of the
party involved specifically directs that
there be a public hearing the matter
becomes public at such time as the
administrative law judge issues and
issues in initial decision if that
decision is adverse to the accountant by
contrast Commission administrative
proceedings other than rule 2 e
proceedings are virtually always public
their Commission's rule 2 e proposal
contains three separate out proposals
favouring of public hearings first that
such hearings be public unless the
Commission directs otherwise this would
be a reversal of the current Commission
of procedures second that hearing in
specified classes of cases the public or
third that the Commission determined
whether a hearing is to be public or
private on a case-to-case basis the
Commission has received numerous
comments on the proposal and the staff
is currently considering these comments
and we'll make a recommendation for the
Commission to consider in the near
future I may say the recent
conversations with the SEC staff has led
me to believe that that that matters
simply do not come to the Commission for
rule 2 e consideration unless there has
been extremely thorough staff
investigation and a very measured
judgement by the staff that it should
bring the matter to the Commission to
seek action as you know with regard to
the treadway Commission the Commission
issued its final report in October of
1987 the Commission was funded by
various private sector groups including
the AICPA and was headed by Jim Treadway
a former SEC Commissioner the report
includes many positive suggestions for
corporate managers for accountants for
the Commission and for the Congress
including recommendations favoring
mandatory peer review and and regulating
opinion shopping our staff is also
currently studying these recommendations
the Commission is pleased that your
profession along with others has
formulated a group to
monitor and encourage the implementation
of the recommendations contained in that
report of course the activities of
private professional organizations that
set standards and provide gardens are
not the entire answer to effective
disclosure policy oversight
unaccompanied by company and transaction
by transaction basis the Commission has
a responsibility to ensure the fair
presentation of the substance of
transactions and the financial results
of entities this function is most
crucial for new transactions for novel
financial instruments and for economic
difficulties in recognition of the
importance of fair presentation the
division of corporation finance is
substantially increasing the number of
accountants on its staff as I've as I
indicated earlier our goal is to have
accountants comprised half of the
professional staff of the operating
branches of that division the increase
in the accounting staff will enable the
division to better address the
increasing frequency of sophisticated
complex and novel accounting issues as
well as to review more issuers financial
statements as I've indicated earlier
financial disclosure is the heart of our
disclosure system and it is the
accountants viewpoints in the
accountants presentations the
accountants accuracy which preserves
those statements for the public in
addition to encouraging the accounting
profession to improve financial
disclosure and to strengthening its own
review process and the division of
corporation finance the Commission is
also enhancing its enforcement process
the Commission devote substantial
resource in its resources and its
division of enforcement to uncovering
and prosecuting instances involving
accounting and financial reporting
abuses when the Commission staff
discovers instances of financial fraud
or other abuses by registrant's it also
examines the role of the auditor to
determine whether the auditor has aided
and abetted issuer violations of the
federal securities laws or engaged in
improper professional conduct over the
past few years the committee
has brought an increased number of cases
against both issuers and their
accountants for failures in the
financial disclosure process these cases
will be discussed by others in the
program today so I won't dwell on them
here I would note however that a number
of these cases emphasize the
significance of auditor independence as
a means of preventing fraud and other
misconduct I consider these areas to be
a particular importance since they
emphasize to the profession there where
auditors fail in their role the
Commission will take vigorous
enforcement action although I've been
discussing enforcement of the
enhancement of the accountants role in
disclosure I want to add a word about an
area which will affect the accounting
profession for years to come the
internationalization of the securities
markets poses significant challenges to
this country's financial disclosure
system challenges that inevitably will
involve the accounting profession as
foreign issuers expand their use of US
capital markets and domestic issuers
seek seek access to foreign markets our
capital markets are and will be
undergoing a significant change
and who night couldn't give me in 1986
for instance foreign purchases of US
stocks reached 148 billion and US
purchases of foreign stocks totaled 51
billion as compared with 82 and 25
billion in 1985 in addition there has
been a large surge in multi national
debt and equity offerings for example
between 1980 and 1986 offerings in the
international bond market including the
Euro bond markets grew from 38 billion
to 227 billion international bond
trading volume in 1986 was more than 3.5
trillion dollars and total international
bond offerings equaled 102 billion in
the first half of 1987 international
equity market says they also shown
remarkable growth euro equity offerings
grew from 220 million dollars in 1983 to
almost 12 billion dollars in 1986 and in
the first half of 1987 total seven and
one half billion there is no doubt that
this internationalization of the markets
brings great benefits to issuers and
investors but it also presents difficult
new challenges foremost among these
challenges is the development of
adequate disclosure standards given the
importance of financial disclosure a key
element of international disclosure
still the standards will be to develop
mutually acceptable international
accounting and auditing standards the
Commission already has a number of
important steps underway to facilitate
this process since 1982 for example the
Commission has had a separate integrated
disclosure system for offerings of
foreign securities registered under the
Securities Act under this system
financial statements do not have to be
prepared in accordance with us gaap if
they comply with gap in the home country
as long as the net income and balance
sheet totals are reconciled to what they
would have been if US requirements have
been followed additionally the
Commission staff is developing a
proposal with other countries for
reciprocal disclosure for the
registration of certain
supplied security the goal is to allow
the offering document from an issuer's
home country to be used as the
prospectus for offerings in the United
States one of the difficult reciprocity
reciprocity issue is being examined by
the staff concerns financial statements
since accounting principles auditing
standards and auditor independence are
critical to the integrity and
credibility of the u.s. disclosure
system it is also essential that any
cooperative approach emphasized the
importance of these well-established
standard setting systems in financial
statement statements regarding
accounting standards an important
objective in the international area is
the identification of reliable
reciprocal accounting standards true
reciprocity would allow an issuer to
prepare only one set of disclosure
documents for worldwide use and would
not have a reconciliation requirement we
hope that continued development and
refinement of international accounting
standards will result in movement
towards similar accounting standards and
will lessen the need for country to
country reconciliation in contrast to
accounting standards auditing standards
differences are not susceptible to
accommodation through reconciliation we
have urged compliance with us gas and we
believe progress in the development of
international auditing standards has
taken place we are encouraged that these
standards may be relied upon for
reciprocity in the future the Commission
will continue to work with international
organizations such as the International
Accounting Standards Committee the
International Federation of accountants
and the international organization of
securities commissions and similars
agent agencies in order to further
efforts to bring about greater
reconciliation and reciprocity I
encourage your participation in these
efforts I would like to make one
statement about the international area
we are in the process that the
commission of developing report on the
market events of October that mark that
market study will include a section
on the relationship of the US markets to
international markets and as one reviews
the events of those a market of that
market crash in October and looks at the
systems which are now in place including
or order routing systems systems which
provide quotation information and last
price information one sees and
automation of the entire securities
markets which will I think inevitably
lead to a greater internationalization
of the markets and what we are going to
see I'm sure is the trading of many US
securities in overseas markets and
efforts to have overseas securities
traded in in our markets this this
progress will occur and the job of the
Securities and Exchange Commission with
the help of the accounting profession
will be to see that the disclosures in
these financial markets are in
accordance as closely as possible with
our standard I believe that our
financial disclosure standards and the
efforts of the accounting profession in
in helping to achieve those standards
has been a one strong and fundamental
reason for the development of fine
capital markets in the United States and
I'm hoping that by by persuasion and
example we in the United States can
increase the amount of disclosure which
occurs in other markets and contribute
to sound stable and honest international
markets may I conclude my remarks by
emphasizing the significance of the
accounting profession to the economy of
the United States our economy depends on
capital markets and those markets depend
on a first-class financial disclosure
system as auditors and accountants you
are responsible for the credibility of
the financial disclosure system the
Commission has been a partner with your
profession for over 50 years and
partnership has worked well as with
every partnership however effort must be
invested to assure that the terms of the
partnership are fulfilled the Commission
will continue to monitor the professions
activities and will proceed through
oversight rulemaking and enforcement
action where necessary to seek excellent
in our nation's full disclosure system
thank you